qui a eu cette idée folle un jour
d'inventer l'école leçons de français de
géographie un terreau de physique de
mathématiques que deux travaillent et on
n'a pas encore parlé des sciences
sociales
comment faire pour remplacer les
interros et le train-train de cloud un
terreau cloud un terreau on va pas
chercher midi à quatorze heures on va
juste prendre un programme de sueur
social que dans il ya là un pont on
arrête les 1 0 et ont fait son portfolio
et la page 45
on nous dit ceci le portfolio de l'élève
ensemble de production significatives à
propos d'une compétence là parfois ou
danser progressif est un parc un
document conçu conseillé par l'élève il
contient des traces de son apprentissage
c'est brouillon ses premières
productions ces corrections ses
réflexions sur les stratégies qu'ils
aient l'évolution constatée une
production finale nature en rapport avec
les compétences et amplifié au départ et
chaque semaine vous observez autour de
vous ce qui se passe 1 ce qui se passe
autour de vous ce sont des faits sociaux
et indiqué ces faits sociaux d'euros
porte folio vous allez me dire mais je
ne fais que ça bah oui dans un premier
temps parce qu'après au coup on va
développer on va découvrir différents
concepts c'est peut-être que vous même
dans vos recherches vous allez trouver
des différents concepts différents
modèles différentes théories différents
auteurs qui vont vous permettre
d'étudier ça mais je vois mon voisin qui
sort avec ses pantoufles dans la rue ben
achour samedi peu original je le mets
dans mon portfolio et après tu me rends
compte qu'en fait il a enfreint des
normes sociales des choses non écrite
d'avoir tout le monde sait qu'on ne sort
pas en pantoufles dans la rue et bien
l'huile enfreint une règle donc c'est
vous qui allez construire votre
portfolio
qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire d'autres
vous pouvez prendre des articles qui
parlent de faits sociaux et les résumer
tout simplement vous aussi vous poser
question des questions de départ même si
vous ne faites pas la recherche vous
pouvez vous poser la question vous
pouvez également faire une petite
recherche
nous avons déjà réussi à gagner
énormément de points avec une petite
recherche pour vous aider il ya bien sûr
une grille d'évaluation qui reprend
toutes les tâches qu'on peut réaliser
dans le portfolio et si je sais pas quoi
faire dans le portfolio qu'est ce que je
fais à bien vous notez vos difficultés
dans le portfolio wing sayat pack corps
faire noté pourquoi est-ce que vous
bloquez avec le portfolio c'est aussi ça
le portfolio c'est de dépasser vos
difficultés
donc si vous comprenez pas quelque chose
d'assez déjà voilà facile de trouver ce
qu'il faut mettre dans le portfolio
ces choses que vous n'avez pas compris
aux cours en ce compris le portfolio
d'autres exemples de ce qu'on peut
mettre dans le portfolio ce sont vos
représentations de quelque chose vous
voyez par exemple une blague raciste ça
vous dérange parce que vous
personnellement vous considérez que les
êtres humains sont égaux et que la
couleur de peau ne joue pas sur nos
qualités intrinsèques à bien voter dans
le portfolio votre grand mère vous dit
que c'était mieux avant qu'avant les
élèves travaillaient plus à l'école que
deux sont en partie patate à la volonté
dans le portfolio
ne tombez pas dans le journal intime
dans la revue de presse vous allez voir
différentes et sociaux qui vont être
déjà débattu en classe vous pouvez
réagir par rapport à ceux ci vous poser
une question de recherche ensuite
formuler des hypothèses peut-être
chercher un autre document qui va
vérifier ou pas votre hypothèse où qui
va d'apporter des concepts nouveaux
et voilà vous avez une dizaine de points
facilement gagné dans le portfolio
bref il faut mettre de tout importe le
lieu alors ça peut paraître compliqué au
premier abord mais moi je vous assure
que si vous prenez le plus vous allez
avoir vous allez apprendre beaucoup de
choses parce que vous allez être
autonome dans votre apprentissage vous
allez aller sur des choses qui vous
attire plus et donc c'est des choses que
vous allez mémoriser à long terme c'est
pas du par coeur
vous allez étudier vous à les restituer
à l'interrogation et que vous avez
oublié de trois jours plus tard c'est ce
que permet parfois les eaux alors on
fait peut-être moi ça peut paraître
parfois on n'est pas à cette chose mais
ce conte seront travail de cette manière
là finalement on ne retient
définitivement c'est ce qu'on cherche
aussi le portfolio va nous permettre
aussi d'avoir un parcours individualisé
c'est à dire que chacun a va aller à son
rythme grâce à ce portfolio si on à
faire certains d'entre vous qui
préfèrent travailler deux heures sur le
port folio le week end mais ils peuvent
travailler deux heures sur le
portoricain si certains aiment bien
faire des synthèses d'articles vont
faire beaucoup de synthèse d'articles
l'idée c'est aussi sur le portfolio de
faire un peu de tout quoi de travail et
aussi ses points faibles
donc ça je vais vous guider
évidemment sur ce qui ne va moins bien
pour que vous puissiez accueillir
l'ensemble des compétences et que vous
poussiez être finalement un élève
complet dans le cours de sciences
sociales surtout si j'ai un conseil à
vous donner par rapport aux core folio
c'est de le faire régulièrement
si vous travaillez régulièrement 20
minutes tous les cinq jours
enfin deux fois par semaine faussaire
c'est un bon rythme mais finalement ça
va passer assez vite
vous avez peut-être avoir des choses du
genre est un oui pour nous pour fallu
que je mette ça vous le notez sur un
petit post-it vous mettez sur votre
bureau vous notez pour pas oublier
l'idée et puis quand c'est le jour où
travailler pour soyaux et vous prenez ce
petit post it vous avez remarqué l'idée
vous le réfléchissez là dessus et hop
vous êtes parti donc finalement les
idées elles vont venir comme ça si vous
commencez à travailler ça régulièrement
elles vont venir assez facilement
l'effort est à faire au début mais
surtout il faut c'est comme c'est comme
plonger du grand du grand plongeur à la
piscine qui peut y aller une fois qu'on
l'a fait une fois on prend le pli et ça
ça fonctionne donc ça pour ça faites moi
confiance lancé vous soyez régulier et
tout ira bien et vous allez voir vous
allez retirer beaucoup de choses en tout
cas c'est ce que j'espère cette vidéo
est maintenant finie et n'oubliez pas de
sacrés sacré charlemagne à bientôt
qui a eu cette idée folle un jour
d'inventer l'école
[Musique]
c'est ray charles
sacré chars
à